Oscar Wilde once pointed out that while
we look to the dramatists to give
romance to realism we asked the actress
to give realism to romance the immensely
talented women nominated tonight for
Best Actress do just that and more the
nominees for Best Performance by an
actress in a leading role are Brenda
Blethyn in secrets and lies Diane Keaton
in Marvin's Room
Frances McDorman in Fargo
Kristin Scott Thomas in the English
Patient Emily Watson in breaking the
waves the Oscar goes to the Oscar goes
to Frances McDorman
it is impossible to maintain one's
composure in this situation what am I
doing here especially considering the
extraordinary group of women with whom I
was nominated three five women were
fortunate to have the choice not just
the opportunity but the choice to play
such rich complex female characters and
I congratulate producers like working
title and Polygram for allowing
directors to let allow in directors to
make autonomous casting decisions based
on qualifications and not just market
value
I encourage writers and directors to
keep these really interesting female
roles coming and while you're at it you
can throw in a few for the men as well
my family friends and colleagues here
tonight and all around the world they
know exactly who they are you know who
you are and I hope you already know how
much your support and your care means to
me
but I'm going to name three the
co-writer director and producer of Fargo
mr. Ethan Coen who helped make an actor
of me his brother mr. Joel Coen who made
a woman of me and our Moon and our son
mr. Pedro McDormand Cohen who's made a
real mother of me thank you for
acknowledging our work
you